hi good evening everybody
welcome to the Development Committee
19th of December 2019 are usually
emergency evacuation announcement should
we be required to evacuate the building
would you please leave the building via
the nearest available exit to the
chamber our assembly point won't be in
the public car park at the side of the
Civic suite please don't delay your
evacuation by collecting any belongings
please don't return into the building
until given permission to do so by
council staff please also note that the
meeting won't be audio recorded and if
you have your mobile turn it to silent
or off please thank you apologies for
absence and substitute members who have
apologies from councillor eaves who
won't be substituted by councillor mrs.
Mason
counts the Western hung be substituted
by councillor mrs. good Inc Thank You
non-members attending I see we have
counselors Lumley Wilkinson and Dre
thank you
minutes of the meeting held on the 21st
of November 2019 subject to an amendment
on item 4 which needs to include at the
top of page 12 that councillor F D is
noted that he vote needs to be noted
that he voted against the above decision
which was minute 2 1 3 3 to 45 Alexander
Road great Wakering other than that are
you happy for me to sign those minutes
as a correct and accurate record of that
meeting thank you so item 5 declarations
of interest councillor Dre
okay thank you
[Music]
mrs. Mason I think yeah I know this
cancer getting yeah okay right so on to
item six your membership of the town
council is declared in public knowledge
item six n nineteen Hawk well chase pork
well there is a tiny little bit of an
addendum for that as everybody seen
sight of that and just noting that this
item would normally be delegated but it
comes to committee because of a council
connection chairman the application it's
to a site on a corner plot and fronting
hawk while closed and the application is
for a single story rare extension which
would extend across the entire width of
the property and take you to the next
slide please
so these are the elevations so show that
the the side side elevation here and
here it doesn't have any fenestration on
it all the fenestration is to the rear
elevation its single-story it's got flat
roof form and extends across the entire
width if I can take you to the street
scene you'll see that the because the
site and if you just go down one please
because it's on a corner plot the
extension will be visible but only
slightly above this rebound offense
German the application is fairly common
for single story extensions and the
recommendation is one of approval thank
you
I remember actually wish to comment on
this okay all right members I move the
recommendation for approval on prep will
be printed on page 6.1 on those members
in favor please indicate thank you that
is unanimously the only other item on
tonight's agenda item 7a referred item
from the weekly list number 41 crown
hill railing thank you right this
application relates to a site along
crown Hill number 41 the application
site is situated on the southern side of
Crown Hill outside Raley town center and
situated some 175 metres from Raley
train station this is a reserved matters
application previously an outline
application we've all matters reserved
was granted County Commission subject to
conditions for five flats matters was
matter x' were reserved for a later
stage and the matters reserved relate to
access landscaping appearance layout and
scale therefore this reserved matters
application relates to those matters and
seek permission for two and a half story
building comprising five two-bedroom
flats layout landscaping car parking and
refusing recycle store please no reserve
mat matters application is not an
opportunity to re-examine the principle
development which has already been
established by the granting of the
outlined plan
mission and the eight and the main
issues which require considerations part
determination of this application are
those matters previously mentioned yeah
so this is sorry so this is the I'm
going to show you a few photographs
which relate to the application site and
its surrounding just to give you an idea
of its context so this is the
neighboring property when you're
standing looking at the property to the
left if you can go that way frankly and
this is opposite the property succeeds
like a two and a half story property's
been sort of extended over time and
again this is opposite the very two
storey properties and again there's
number two story property you see here
there's a balcony there's prevalence in
the front of the premises this is
opposite the site again and there's
favorite two-story properties you see
there's a mix of sort of low profile
bungalows and against two-story
properties as well as free story so if
you keep going this is named property
the opposite side on the right-hand side
of the property
and this is a bit further down the road
towards the train station so you can see
these are free stock three-story
dwellings along these are adjacent to
the free story block of flats that are
opposite the train station and again
this is looking the opposite direction
up crown hill towards the town centre
and so it's just showing you sort of the
context of free story dwellings next to
this Chalet style bungalow in two-story
property so you can down long again and
it's not a picture the flat and these
are the Chalet style Pung raised on the
other side the free story property so it
kind of gives you an idea of the context
of site and I mean Crown Hill the
topography slopes sort of towards the
town centre and in sort of the like to
towards the rear site as well
and if we can go to elevations please
and so to show you the context site so
you've got an idea of what the street
looks like and these the elevations and
given the context of the site situate
from the mix of different style of
properties along Crown Hill is
considered that the appearance layout
scale is acceptable in this instance it
goes my plan for me and so this site
plan before you shows
the layout of the site should show you
the car parking the footprint the boom
that's proposed as well as stuff
landscaping and so yes this plan
illustrates often the hard landscaping
to the front that's to be laid out and
this would also incorporate five car
parking spaces and the proposal would
utilize an existing vehicle access off
crown Hill and landscaping pros and
access on site is considered acceptable
and some visuals have been provided just
to give you an idea of what they
proposal would look like if kind of
Commission was successful and to round
out to conclude the development is
considered to be acceptable with regards
to neighbors properties the amount of
outdoor private amenity spaces in excess
of what is required by the council's
housing design guide the flats proposed
do called with technical housing
standards and the refuse and recycling
storage would be kept in a recessed area
to the flank of the building this is
considered adequate to store two euro
bins and a food waste bin it's
considered that proposal calls with the
outline planning permission at this site
which has been approved and in print in
principle a building to accommodate five
flats and the layout scale parents
landscape and that access proposed are
considered acceptable and has been
recommended positively thank you thank
you we have three through speakers
who've registered with us
that's it peso Jack Roman Road each am
counseled the main form with this the
main form of development within this
area is a residential in character
containing semi-detached and detached
thought two-story dwellings and
bungalows all of which are not uniform
in design and are on an elevated
position leading to the town center
crane Hill was a crescent-shaped Road
with the residential development
boundary of Riley and a2 under the
conservation area and a main elevated
focal entrance to the town this property
is near nearby a local conservation lay
mark ie the Dutch cottage crane who was
a very busy and congested highway and
the main entrance to the the main
entrance to the conservation area of
Riley town center often congested from
the high street to the Riley Town Center
I would like to say if I'm a chairman
that because there's been changes since
our original obligation of objections
and I did ask permission to just point
out a couple of issues the Flex at the
bottom shown as indicated in the
photograph shortly disea really form
right at the bottom of the hill opposite
the station and pictorially and as an
entrance to the town don't form part of
their illustration is right at the
bottom opposite the railway station and
I felt I was a little slightly
misleading secondly that the the arisen
is show that where the we did objects
have been storage but I note that that's
been changed during this process and
right to say that with the new bin
storage as it suggested restricts access
at the size of the building and it would
cause difficulty and getting the bins
out and bringing around to a front which
would lit which although
cannot be told it does feel as though
there will be a tendency to leave the
bins out because it would be easier than
putting them in the bins into the
storage so the chain Council objects to
this application because it is not over
development and not in keeping with the
total street scene the proposed plains
overlook neighboring properties I've
already mentioned the bin storage and
there are no elephants scuse me and
there are no
located spaces for disabled or guests
parking and the principle that we might
be able to park elsewhere Lisa 2 added
another concern that were the visitors
to the tent will have nowhere to park
because of all the residents being there
and it appears to be an inadequate space
for vehicles to maneuver on the two
parking areas that were near the bidding
stage original beam stage thank the
chairman Thank You Jimmy
good evening councillors my name is Mark
Beckford and I am a director of seven
Elms limited the developer of the
application site known as 41 crown Hill
it is our intention to replace what is a
low quality substandard property on a
large plot with a modern contemporary
architectural II designed building one
which is of high quality specification
and appearance as we've have a project
we have completed I firmly believe that
the fullness of time will prove that the
development will sit well within its
environment and will lift the overall
appearance of the street scene we have
listened to local opinion as well as the
local authority Planning Department and
as a considerate local developer we have
redesigned aspects of the building to
address concerns with regard to scale
appearance and refuse location by using
clever design we've ensured the building
doesn't dominate the street scene we've
used hidden flat roofs we will excavate
the land stagger the rear aspect and
have lowered the roof of the building to
ensure it doesn't overshadow or dominate
the neighboring properties or the street
scene in general we have increased areas
of landscaping to the front of the site
mature green plants he will create a
mixed environment and a street scene in
keeping with its surroundings
furthermore the bins store is now wholly
integrated within the footprint of the
building completely hidden from view
our intention to develop five flats
formed the outline plan application
submitted with details of the site
layout upon which the footprint of the
building was indicated this was approved
earlier this year this process included
Essex highways approving all aspects of
the parking and access arrangements to
and from the site
Essex highways are further approved the
same party and vehicle movement
arrangements a reserved matters stage I
should also point out that the drawings
do provide for adequate cycle storage
on-site a matter which has been missed
and raised as a concern by some in
summary the plans fully comply with all
APO a standards crown Hill is also known
as the a12 9a main road that already
contains several flatted developments
such roads are the preferred choice by
most local authorities for the
development of flats given that such
locations are generally no longer
desirable to families the site in
question lie is almost equidistant
between the train station and the high
street the road contains a very mixed
scene I hope my comments demonstrate why
I firmly believe that development will
sit well within his environment and will
fit will lift the overall appearance of
the street scene I believe that as a
developer we have acted in a positive
and proactive way to mitigate the
concerns of local residents and the cans
were every opportunity as a local
company we are committed to our
community and will act responsibly and
considerate considerably throughout
every stage of this development to
conclude these will be high quality
well-built homes in the right location
built by local trades people and
businesses providing quality desirable
housing for local community one thing in
response to what was said a moment ago I
appreciate the larger block of flats is
at the bottom of the hill is within
eyesight of the site at the top of the
hill the the sort of entrance or gateway
as I think is referred to to the highest
street
I believe ever so slightly down from the
main High Street is another block of
flats which has been there several
decades weave
maybe even flat roofs actually so flats
are very much part of that road thank
you
my name's Phil Hinds and I live at 45
crown Hill right next to the develop a
plot outline planning permission to
demolish the existing two-bedroom
bungalow and construct a two-story block
of five two-bedroom flats was granted by
Roger District Council by solely on a
suggested planned view of the site with
matters regarding access appearance
landscaping layout and scale being
reserved seven neighbors objected and
objected when these plans was put into
the submitted the first replication
provided further information of the
proposed development this submission was
significantly larger than the approved
and then that he proved in the IOP most
significantly it was for a three-story
building fourteen neighbors objected to
the plans this time prompted by the
colossal size and of the proposal and
Rochford District Council rightly
refused and not withdrew planning
permission citing these reasons the new
replication was then submitted via a new
set of documents this was the first time
that the proposed height of the building
had been shown albeit in meters above
sea level in an attempt to fudge the
height of the development the whole of
the third floor has been squashed down
onto the second floor as but can be seen
in this animation that is now animated
the red lines on this slide showed that
the remainder of the building retained
all of its rejected measurements ten
neighbors rejected objected at this time
on the 5th of December a new set of
updated plans were lodged and the
following day the council granted
planning permission no opportunity for
further comment by neighbors or the
public until now apart from not
addressing the council's reasons for
rejecting the first room which all still
apply I would like to address some of
the additional misleading and or
erroneous points made in the development
committee document regarding the
approved second REM point 300 P was
granted for a two-story building or REM
plans show three stories point nine as
has already been stated the original REM
planning application was rejected not
withdrawn point 13 the street puts seen
in this part of Crown Hill consists of
semi-detached and two-story dwellings
providing a strong architectural cue due
to the present shape of the road the
block of flats in the top and the bottom
are not visible from this low
functional balconies are not found on
crown hill point twenty-two and
twenty-three five parking spaces are
insufficient and will crease that's
cause the same problems seen in the
Trinity House development where
residents and visitors are parking in
Philpott house for this development
spices in Lee's way will be used does
this is easily accessible through an
alleyway twenty metres from the
development there is also no provision
for trades to park point 23 parking
spaces have been specified that the size
allowed for exceptional circumstances
the council have tried to justify the
use of this size to buy by citing the
inclusion of a suitable turning area
this is not valid justification there
just isn't enough space for anything
bigger point 26 the front to flank
windows of number 39 are to a lounge and
the proposed development will now
completely block the light to this
habitable room through those windows
points 27 28 and 29 the council have
applied their 45 degree tests from the
middle of the nearest window rear window
as a result of a recent appeal the
details of this appeal show that an
existing part of the development already
broke the 45-degree test and that the
proposed extension would not cause any
further impact to the neighbors if
applied in this way this development
being a new builder does not justify the
45 degree test being applied in its
manner
besides that a screen 1.8 meters higher
nearly 3 meters wide still constitutes a
barrier to the 45 degree test if the
application of the council's 45 degree
test were applied from the edge of the
rear window instead of the middle the
depth of the development would have to
be reduced by over half a meter which
would reduce the floor space for rooms
on the second and third floors point 32
a balcony one floor up and one meter
from our boundary steel breaches our
privacy even though there is an opaque
screen between us this will not fully
block sound and vision amenity space
points 45 and 46 considering that the
rear garden is nearly 300 square meters
and the minimum recommended amenity
space is 25 square metres per dwelling
there is no real reason to provide any
balconies point 47 the latest proposed
beam storage location will be almost
inaccessible due to the parking
arrangements and the proposed
landscaping one final point concerning
the bat survey there is a pond 190
meters from the developer
which wasn't declared in any of the
applications and police showed the last
light thank you thank you I'd like to go
first
Thank You chairman chairman members and
I I know we've heard that certain
aspects of this outline plan commission
would be agreed there are still
considerations to be considered in
regards to scale and bulk and
suitability chairman I've called this
application in from the weekly list for
two reasons first of all is
overdevelopment of the sites and second
it breaches council policies when we
start talk about policies policy dear
and one of the development management
plan states that all developments must
consider a number of factors there are
actually 13 in total the following
points from that list I'm suggesting
have been breached that is they've
either been forgotten or they've been
considered and then completely ignored
parking sufficient car parking in
accordance with policy dm3 and the
parking standards design and good
practice second point has been ignored
avoid overlooking the third points a
positive relationship with the existing
and nearby buildings policy dm3
fourth point scale and form appropriate
to the locality also policy dm3 with
regards to parking chairman the pot
there was a policy called the parking
design
sorry the parking standards design and
good practice this is a national policy
adopted by this council in full council
on the 17th of December 2010 it has not
been updated and it has not been
replaced that policy requires a
residential property with two or more
bedrooms to have a minimum of two spaces
per dwelling it then goes further to say
that each of these spaces must be a
minimum of 5 meters by 2.9 meters the
policy recognizes that at times
sometimes there are certain
circumstances where a slight variation
on that policy may be considered it
recognizes its way in recognizing this
the policy goes further to say this may
be reduced to 5 meters by 2.5 meters in
exceptional circumstances only well what
are exceptional circumstances Chairman
because it doesn't say so the Oxford
English Dictionary gives us some but
some of his some assistance here by
defining the word exceptional as being
unusual or uncommon or abnormal or
extraordinary well where are the unusual
or abnormal or uncommon or extraordinary
circumstances here I've asked this
question and I have not yet received a
response that's it because there are no
exceptional circumstances in my
respectful submission chairman there is
a consistent misuse to the ability to
vary this policy who have even cited the
base size in the officers report as
being the minimum permissible size they
are not the minimum permissible size the
minimum permissible size is 5 meters by
2.9 under normal and ordinary
circumstances in addition to the base
size of the number of bays provided are
woefully insufficient the policy
requires two bays per dwelling it also
requires a quarter of a paper dwelling
for visitor parking this actually
equates to 11 and a quarter spaces at 5
meters by 2.9 meters this proposal is
providing 5 Bay's at 5 meters by 2 to
1/2 meters in civil mathematical terms
German the proposal provides a total of
60 2.5 square meters of parking when it
should if it sticks the policy provide
163 0.125 square meters of parking that
is a shortfall of just over a hundred
square meters of parking this
development is actually providing 38% of
the parking but this policy our policies
require would you regard this as a
slight variation a relaxation or
complete disregard for the policy this
council has adopted
would you mind thank you look at these
slides on the 19th of December 19th of
July apologies this year the previous
application was in fact refused the
planning officer on that occasion cites
the following reasons for its refusal
members chairman if you look at the
slide you can see the left-hand side
slide is day as a generated image of
what the proposal was in July which was
it rejected and the one in the right is
the one that the Planning Department is
saying we should accept so it was
rejected for depth bulk scale height
significantly larger than neighboring
properties out of character with naval
properties over dominance in size
significantly higher contractor policy
cm watt CP 1 of the course
with exception of a couple of windows
there I challenge you to point out the
differences between the two the plot
itself measures 14 meters in width wall
to wall the parking bays even at two and
a half meters wit wide that's the lower
width they take up 12.5 meters in width
would you mind just moving on to the
next slide for me please that's it thank
you
so two and a half meters wide it takes
at twelve point five meters of width so
on the planning portal there was a train
of emails between the planning officer
and an officer from the principal Street
scene about the bins the bins to be
provided a 360 litre size bins measuring
point six meters and width due to the
location of the bin storage and the
opposite side of the building for the
front door that requires two paths once
the front door wants the bin storage
if you accept it's going to take
probably a meter width path to the bin
storage to take her point six meter bin
down more simple mess leaves a half a
meter to the front door
well that doesn't allow anything for
wheelchair access doesn't allow anything
for push chairs doesn't allow anything
at all chairman members in summary I've
pointed out to the clear breaches in our
council policy I've demonstrated to you
that even with his clear breaches even
with the clear breaches the sizes plot
is still too small and the parking
cannot be provided and even with 38%
either even with 38% of the required
parking they still can't provide two
decent sized footpaths this is a clear
example of a massive over development of
this site where the developers with
respect are only interested in
maximizing their profits once they've
completed their work they will walk away
leaving an unacceptable situation for
the residents who live there every day
in addition chairman with respect I must
caution each and every one of you when
you make this decision if you vote to
uphold this decision and approve the
developments what in effect you're doing
is to condone the council ignoring
policy which is adopted by full council
you're allowing council policy to be
rewritten and how can we ever stop that
in the future it will be cited as a
president our council stands on its
policies it is what makes us strong and
hit in the right direction the strength
of any policy is in the consistency in
which its applied consistent every time
if it is bent
warped twisted then that policy is dead
finally chairman the council prides
itself on having the interest of the
residents the heart of everything we do
it is on every single agenda published
by Member Services the officers report
shows over three pages of
representations which would be a lot
more had the local neighbors
representations not been prey stood into
one paragraph it includes an email from
me at the outset of this application was
spelling out the breaches it was opposed
by the town council yet the very next
word and the document is the word of
proof
residents ignored local town council
ignored how has that put in the
residents at the heart of everything we
do
I therefore implore you and all the
members to refuse and fully reject this
application of the grounds that it
breaches policy and it's an over
development of the site thank you thank
you
just just point out obviously counts the
Wilkinson is a visiting member but he
did during his his speech there
intimated that we might not be making a
proper decision and I must point out for
all everyone here tonight that we will
be making a proper decision and we have
proper adjudication of our process so to
ensure so I put a water chestnut that a
proper decision is made thank you I'll
have to move on though councillor drag
Thank You chairman I broadly support the
comments of the three previous speakers
who spoke against the application in my
view mr. chairman this is a three storey
development not a two-story of element
and that is clearly shown on the rear
elevation there's a that was in the
plans in my view also it's clearly an
overbearing site and it's out of
character with the street scene there
are proposed five flats for 19 possible
residents and only five parking spot
bays which clearly insufficient and are
too small in addition mr. chairman there
are no visitor bays also there's no
cycle provision to encourage healthy
living living I'm also concerned mr.
chairman regards to the 45% roll
that was used in respect of the
overlooking of the neighboring site and
that rule is clearly inflate in favor of
the applicant and I again mr. chairman
recommend that this committee refused
his application thank you thank you
council only did you want to say
anything no okay members counselor mrs.
Mason Thank You mr. chairman before I
comment on the report and the
application before us I would like to
ask some questions of the officers for
clarity I can't quite see where the bins
storage is so could someone point that
out to me and the access to it in
so if they're inset into the building
are these going to be the large
four-foot five-foot bins that they
normally have for flats or are they
going to be the small ones that are
commonly using a domestic situation
they're going to be UVO bins the big
large and Ben says I did speak with
waste and straightening scene department
they recommended two euro beatings for
the block of flats there's only room for
two bins there they're only required to
provide two euro beans because the size
of them for the five flats so could have
some clarification on that because
usually we've got three different types
of refuse collection yeah
and yes you would have two bins of those
sorts of five flats but we you can't
just have two bins we've got three types
of conditions no em and the department
explained to me that all 24 weeks
different wastes collected so there we
to yura beans one will be for one
particular ace there'll be one for none
particular weight and then they'd have a
wheelie bin for food waste
yes but if the euro be how are you going
to get access to them and will they drag
down the side
but if Planning Commission was
forthcoming the officers from that
department had to go and visit the
property and assess it and the
consultation we had carried out them and
their devised how it would be accessed
but they have advised that two Europeans
are required at this site as well as a
wheelie bin for the feed waste the other
question I'd like to ask see is one of
the reserved matters was car parking and
highways access basically normally when
we have an application of this sort we
have an opinion from Essex highways I
don't see that in the offices report did
you obtain one we consulted them but
they didn't they didn't comment this
time however they have commented
previously for the outline and the
previous reserved matters that we had in
this application they didn't raise any
objections the access is existing and
there isn't anything any control over
that and the car parking spaces that are
laid out you know is a sustainable
location parking standards do require a
reduction in this type of area and but
previously they didn't raise any
objections to it and they recommended
conditions they didn't raise any
objections to the access either no okay
and just another question mr. chairman
if you'll bear with me on this because
it does seem to be a rather complex
situation the outline planning
permission that has been granted as far
as I can see is for five flats correct
of two storeys
it doesn't say five two-bedroom flats or
five one-bedroom classics for five flats
is that correct
and a total hiding together of two
storeys so had they been one-bedroom
flats then you would have expected them
to take up this bulk of mess yeah
potentially yes and I think he's only
for five flats it didn't it didn't
express how much the size no that's all
I needed to know thank you okay Thank
You mr. chair I'm probably want to speak
on it later but I'd like to hear what
other members fenceless Stanley
Thank You chairman just a couple of
pointers all the the flats are actually
double bedrooms what we're talking about
so they will occupy four adults and some
of them can occupy fall and there are
one or two that can occupy free I mean
one also have any what's one or two
on the plan yes a free love free of the
flats can accommodate for and to the
flats can accommodate free people they
all - but there are two bedrooms so
there's 20 21 occupants at all
ten sorry okay yeah potentially up to
you think for the just members clarity
could I just ask you to be precise about
the status of the previous application
and then clearly car parking has been
the subject of some discussion yeah if
you could elaborate a little bit further
about how your decision on car parking
standards was arrived relating to the
location and the previous reserved
matters application and it was actually
withdrawing a decision wasn't made
however a report did go on like they did
on the weakness but it was withdrawn so
a decision was never made it was a drawn
because of concerns that were previously
raised by offices and we've regards to
the car parking there are only five car
parking spaces so one per flat they are
and they do measure to the minimum size
bays
rather than the preferred size bays and
it is a sustainable location the parking
stands do require or do allow for a
reduction in car parking we've regards
to the size of the bays and they are two
point five by five and Alex like it is
in the preferred measurement it's a
minimum measurement and we've just used
on we justified this on the basis that
there is adequate turn area within the
site so they can turn within the start
and exit the site safely and also with
this size bays it requires an excessive
amount of soft landscaping that will
soften the appearance of the building
that was another reason for us allowing
it and also there are sort of other
examples within the area that has also
allowed similar bay sizes and so that
was also considered as a part of of the
recommendation of this application I
hope that helps
and with regard to the location of the
property and the proximity to the town
center I'm okay yeah he's a long Crown
Hill it's 175 metres from the train
station in the opposite direction you do
have the high street so it is considered
a highly sustainable location because of
the public sort of services sort buses
trains walking distance to places and
there are plenty of local means he's in
the new facility so he's a highly
sustainable location and that's why
reduction of car parking spaces has been
accepted in this case it was actually
saying the previous application as well
it wasn't refused it's with Jordan and
it wasn't refused it wasn't refused and
highway grounds either but like I say we
did buy a recommendation for a few on
design grounds not on highway reasons
and like I said that was redrawn to
decisions never actually issued for that
one okay councillor Wilson Thank You
chairman a couple of points one is that
do we know whether they're a double
yellow line outside the property near
East W lines all along Crown Hill so it
wouldn't be safe for anyone to park
along that road also I haven't found the
area and I know sort of leads way there
were some concerns and that people
raised about car parking in that area
and they are single lines but there are
car parking restrictions because the
railway and the train station and so it
would people be at leave their cars
there all day without or seeing
potentially get a ticket if so second
point was about the 45 degree rule have
we taken with this particular
development have we taken it from where
we normally take from the building or is
it the case that it's from a different
position he's been taken from the middle
and as someone who previously raised
earlier about the we had a recent appeal
decision come in for a site in little
Wakering and this was for householder
extension the inspector ruled that
because out our policy or our guideline
in the years in this sub princey
planning document to house in design
isn't specific in saying where we should
taking the measurement front ok
historically we've taken it from the
edge or the window where because it
doesn't state that in the guidance the
inspector has gone with that and allowed
that application to be the 45-degree
rule to be taken from the middle that we
know and so that is a pure decision it
does hold some sort material weight
within there any decision that's being
made so in this instance we have taken
it from the middle because of that
recent of your decision it's just an
observation actually that there are
three story buildings they're actually
at the boundary of the properties at the
bottom because they are at the bottom we
don't really interfere with anything
else and the properties at the top and
what we're looking at here is putting
something effectively three stories in
the middle just nice you know any
members who haven't spoken yet want to
speak I'll come back to counts to Stan
Lee then oh sorry they they are
clarification points just continuing
from from was saying and will you be
right to say that it was up for
recommendation of refusal before it was
withdrawn the application in July and
that's why that appeared on their report
yes that's correct
thank you and in when you refer to the
car parking spaces being to the minimum
standards is that minimum standards in
all circumstances or minimum standards
in exceptional circumstances that's one
of the speakers previously it suggested
and I mean the Pakistan to say
exceptional circumstances and then
counsel Wilkerson did go through you'll
see definitions etc and the reason
unfortunately at least to say what
exceptional circumstances are however
because of the ternary insight the
amount of landscapes has been provided
we've considered that to be reasons to
allow a minimum bay size as well there
are refer examples within the town
center that also recent development has
been allowed of a same
and base sizes that but also been
proposed the minimum that's why I've
allowed in this instance yeah thank you
for - appreciate okay counselor Wharton
chairman Thank You M we come to these
meetings and and here regularly
applicants developers wanting
understandably to develop a particular
area on the face of it it looks to me
gross over development in terms of what
they're trying to achieve on the site so
we understand a developer's point of
view and they can't be blamed for that
in terms of trying to apply all the
national framework in terms of planning
but then we hear from four people who in
a very rational and unemotional way
present their case using policy examples
to support their case and I have to
admire the way that each of them
presented their points but what we end
up with as a committee is finding
ourselves not quite well I'll speak for
myself for when three brothers and I
find myself totally drawn in the sense
of not actually understanding whether
the points that have been made we
obviously have to comply with policy so
in May in reaching our decision we have
to comply with policy but we've heard
numerous cases where there appears to be
examples where this application is at
odds with our policy and it's been very
eloquently and articularly articulately
supported so I get really quite
concerned that we reach this stage of
making a decision on an application when
there is clearly what appears to be a
void on a whole range of issues
thank you chair ok cancer Stanley
thank you just to just to come back a
little a couple of points if we are as
so put by the officer just to refer that
so we're now looking from the center of
a window outwards on 45 degrees that
means that all those in the past that we
have refused will actually come back to
us and tell us they won't go you could
have passed that at the center of the
window because it's not at the edge of
the window so we can't adapt ourselves
to benefits to benefit others because we
think it's a noise development we should
carry out what we intend to do from the
off and that is the off as the stance we
have taken and that's where we should be
at the edge of the window secondly I
have my worries on forward prevention
and how how there how that building will
actually work in emulation ii thought i
hazards and that sort of thing so and
that to me is another big big no-no
because the more people you've got 21
people going in there and we all know
what that happens people make mistakes
people do things and and that could lead
to a really disaster area not only for
that property but the property is next
door the other thing that really worries
me is that we have a policies we have
policies that in the past have worked
for us and we seem to be mitigating
those policies in the way of well we've
just bend over this way to help and
we've just been this way to help that
person on that so on I do find that we
should stick to our policy we should
stick to our guns on what we are
intending for developers to to go by and
and this is a this is another case that
we are actually sort of mitigating
ourselves rather than bringing policy to
fact
so mrs. Mason Thank You mr. chairman I
apologize for the phone it's a new one I
don't know how to turn it off so I'm not
as articulate as some of the previous
speakers who I think have spoken
exceptionally well and covered a lot of
aspects of this application so forgive
me if my summary is less articulate
however if we look at the items that we
are considering we're not considering we
have permission for five flats in this
position but everything else
citing car parking access is reserved
therefore we should look at though
I usually have it in the car the
officers report if I start that there
was a sighting appearance the officers
report says to the residential in
character containing semi-detached and
detached two-story dwellings and
bungalows and this is bungalows and semi
detached and detached so there's a
variation a size in characteristics and
I think we all know that rode quite well
this particular proposal first of all
it's linear with the adjacent property
so that that variation and
characteristic ease and that there's no
positive relationship it will break up
that especially being in the middle so I
do think the site and appearance as the
as shown that it fails when I go to
parking standards I see no no reason at
all why our parking standards should not
be a dear to and I'm quite concerned
that on a new development there is no
provision for a cyclist or there's no
provision for visiting residents bearing
in mind the car park is some distance
away and often full up and offer any
disabled visitors I'm concerned from
that point of view the overlooking again
I think that's been well covered and is
an aspect that we should show concern of
it is basically in my view bulk a mess
they comes down to scale and bulk and it
is overdevelopment of this site in my
view and I would certainly be happy to
move for refusal based on the issues
have been raised by various members if
someone would like to second
okay could you'd like to say a few words
and if you can also particularly mention
this icon store because that is one yep
so just just to clarify there is a cycle
store pose but I don't think we've
specifically pointed it out to you so
maybe we'll just do that just to set
minds at rest that at least that point
would be accommodated so there is space
to the rear where cycles could be stored
so I would perhaps guard against putting
the lack of any cycle provision on-site
into any reason for refusal but what I
have taken from the points just raised
if I could just summarize is that okay
the reasons for refusal that understood
so far and so primarily in perhaps
firstly it's a concern with the scale
and massing of this building that's
proposed over development yes is a
primary primary reason especially when
you look at the comparison between the
surrounding areas in this particular
part of the street seaming that
particular part of the street swing the
fact that we have proved something in
the past and made a mistake doesn't mean
that we have to do the same thing again
okay the the other I'm sorry in relation
to that I know you mentioned the sort of
lack of setback the the fact that the
building would be in line with the
neighboring properties may be
exaggerating that sort of dominance in
the street scene then we've talked about
overlooking and over dominance original
layout though there's an approval for
five flats that moved it's so far
forward it changed it would grossly
change the character at the street scene
and one other thing I am concerned about
which I didn't mention which forgive me
is that this I believe is a balcony at
the front
but that is a road where you've
constantly got traffic queuing and fumes
so one of the reasons sometimes that
balconies are put in is to increase the
floor space of the flat and we're doing
there and sit submit to conform to
standards but who would want to sit on a
balcony when the stationary traffic and
traffic there I don't think just from a
think just for clarity council may miss
nice and if you officers point of view
in their interpretation of your motion
for refusal if you could just stick to
explaining those things okay sorry
so I have a cop what I what I've got so
fighter and a primary reason for refusal
number one to do with the scale and
massing of this development in this
particular part of the street scene I'm
taking into account it being brought
forward within the site because of the
scale of the development price being
five too bad flats and the consequent
size of the development they're void yes
scale will include height massing depth
etc mcclee taking issue with the balcony
to the front of the on the basis that it
is it's a is somewhat personal choice
you know and maybe most people wouldn't
want to sit out on a balcony in that
location some might I think it being a
reason for refusal wouldn't support that
general concern about scaling and
massing in that location but I'll come
to the other points like so we need to
be clear about these reasons for a fuse
or so overlooking and over dominance
were mentioned I think we need to be
clear it is for members to determine
whether this developments would be
acceptable in terms of scale in relation
to neighboring properties really it's
only these two neighboring properties
that would have be directly affected by
the proposal so we need to be clear
about the overlooking an over dominance
what they have proposed in the
application is this privacy screen here
which would be to a height that would
obstruct sort of a adult person standing
and looking directly into this sort of
private area of this neighboring
property here I know the speed one of
the speakers did talk about it being an
a opaque screen and actually that
wouldn't completely prohibit this
impression of people being there even if
the direct you know you can't actually
see directly because there's a it's
obscured and potentially you're over
dominance concerns arise around that
more generally the 45-degree angle
wouldn't be breached by the developments
that sort of the the wall the rear wall
even if you took it from the middle of
the window next door but the screen
would so this screen here to this
balcony you know would breach that and
so it's just understanding from members
about this reason in terms of is it just
this property here is it the neighboring
property to the other side as well just
formulate a reason around that
if he obscures which he will do and I do
know that if you put an obscure screen
up there it won't give the same format
as being open as it would be closed deep
so it's just not putting offense that
they didn't cast so that would ensue
but that would still did the 45 degree
from the corner of the window then that
means their policy and he would cut
across not only back
so counsel Mason just to go back as I
think you're you're the person that's
sort of primarily putting the same
reasons refusal forward I'm am i clear
that York you are concerned about
overlooking and over dominance in
relation to the neighboring property to
this side because if the if the Belkin
masse wasn't so great
they wouldn't need the screening okay
it's just an unreasonable relationship
between those properties yes so okay
because wouldn't need to cover it if it
was essentially you're saying it success
its successive yeah and it's also okay
because I know you've mentioned parking
so we need to be clear is there a reason
for refused all around parking being
inadequate or what God against that
reason solely relating to the base sizes
but I think the broader concern has been
with the number of parking spaces
proposed it is in a location that we've
sort of acknowledged in the
recommendation that you could argue is
highly sustainable they are there are
though large flats proposed so it's not
five small one bed flats which could be
a proposal that might come forward at a
later date on the site and that would
still comply with the outline planning
consent is four five sorry five too bad
larger properties so I think your
concern is to do with the scale of the
property is proposed and the amount of
parking the lack of visitor parking the
lack of visiting party that the the
number of parking spaces bearing in mind
the type of property proposed and also
the the fact that the base sizes I do
not
we have a policy if this was an existing
it would be different issue a new build
they should be to make the base sizes
adequate so over development in
assessment in essence yes yeah okay
right so I've just got you in a minute
we're all the members clear about the
reasons for refusal that have been
stated right or just how a couple of
members just want to speak on those
prior to us going to a vote on this
councillor getting disability access as
well which I think should be
sure Thank You chairman that was my main
concern these five car parking spaces
but there's no parking for disabled
people though okay okay hefty chairman
um cats the mice mrs. Mason pointed out
the pike at the back is there access by
both sides of the property to the back
or just one
I can't quite make out
yeah
yeah so you can see on the floor plan in
front you there is a doorway there there
will be a gate on the opposite side on
the left-hand side but you can see on
the right-hand side where there's a
porch access into the building there is
a door going out the back there so you
so if you want to get right for you'd
have to actually go through the building
you can go for the building or you can
go around the side and go up the access
whether it be around the other side yeah
I go over so you want me to get my crew
recess them no these free six yes you
can gain access to that garden thank you
okay members just for for my comment
prior to us going to a vote
I've sat here quite quite a number of
years and there are there are
controversial applications that come in
front of us and this is this is
certainly one the principle of something
happening there is not in question that
sorted out I'm relatively uncomfortable
about the the parking is a reason for
refusing because we've we've been down
this slope this route on so many
occasions in such a sustainable location
so close to the strange station so close
to the town centre with all its bus
routes there are five spaces they're
certainly the three in the middle are
undersized but you could argue that the
two on the end with the the paths going
down the size or acceptable so I be a
little bit uh uncomfortable with that
we've also got a number of members that
have been talking about policies as if
they're sort of black and white if our
policies were black and white we
wouldn't need the officers sits in it
sitting by the side of us policies get
interpreted in all sorts of different
ways for all sorts of different
different reasons and the officers have
interpreted the policies in the way that
has led them to make a recommendation
for approval on this occasion in terms
of the the bomb can scare one crown
Hillary is a very mixed environment of
properties there there are all
thoughts within easy vision and I I
suspect that might be difficult to
defend but the thing that just tips it
over for me is that if this was five
one-bedroom flats I don't think would be
where we are now but five two-bedroom
flats is a slightly different kettle of
fish so I find this application a very
finely balanced judgment but I'm just
persuaded by the scale of mass because
they are 2-bedroom properties so on that
basis I will be concurring with the the
polity recommendation for fusional
that's been perp so members we are clear
about the recommendations the officers
are safe to them I don't think we need
to to restate those so its motion for
refusal from councillor Mason
I took councillor Wilson as the the
second handout on though there were
there are a number of hands those
members in favor of the refusal please
indicate right that item is refused so I
believe this is the last formal public
meeting of this year so it is happy
Christmas to everyone and we'll see you
in the new year for more of the same
thank you